bring a new feature
level or environment to life in a matter
of days
or weeks and actually feel how fun it is
now some of these ideas will work and
others won't
but the ones that make it into our games
will be awesome
who better to show you what i'm talking
about than the guys that cried tearing
games
they know a thing or two about speed now
listen
we don't typically show things this
early and let's be clear
this is early but it's also very cool
and let's be honest we all know that
there's no way we could keep this a
secret anyway
at criterion we come from a world
predominantly experienced through cars
it's time for us to explore new
adventures
imagine what that could be
so with criteria it's all about the
experience our history is in cars
going really fast and taking big risk
high action okay with physical boots
we've got wing suits we've got
parachutes crazy combinations of
vehicles jumping over each other through
each other
under each other tied together what's
the most exciting thing i can do
in a plane on a jet ski there's not a
single vehicle that we've talked about
that i
don't find exciting really been inspired
by what we've seen people sharing in the
real world
that the first person views the movies
that they take are almost like
athletes point of view we've absolutely
been influenced by all the amazing
action footage that people are capturing
and putting on youtube this is a
first-person game
we're not gonna ever take you out of
that so if you get in a vehicle you're
gonna climb in the vehicle your hands
are actually gonna touch these things
and it means an expanded landscape so
many different types of terrain that
we've never been able to explore before
our players can go anywhere they can
make any experience they want
you're walking around our world and
you're just looking at the vehicles and
the scenery
it feels epic it really is an ultimate
game for us
it's a criterion game so it's going to
be fun this is going to be the biggest
game criterion's ever made